okay today i'm going to talk to you
about halogen reaction
there's three different types of
reaction that we need to know involving
halogens
okay so just to recap halogens are group
seven are in group seven of the periodic
table so fluorine
chlorine bromine iodine and astatine and
they undergo some reactions that we're
going to look at now
so the first type of reaction that we
need to know about
is their reaction with
metals so
i'm going to show you a nice simple
example it's a really simple reaction
so they basically um halogens will react
vigorously with some metals to produce
salts called
metal halides so here's an example here
sodium plus chlorine
makes sodium
chloride okay
so just to show you um the similar
equation underneath
the metals all by itself chlorine here
is
our halogen chlorine and we're forming
sodium chloride now just to balance it
i need to do this now it's a really
simple reaction
but we need to know about this substance
which is formed here
this is called a metal
halide so it's a really really simple
reaction between a metal
and a halogen to make a metal halide
sodium chloride for example
if we react with a different um halogen
for example
fluorine we'd make sodium fluoride
instead notice that when the halogens
all by itself it ends in ine
and when it's in a compound it ends ide
the next type of reaction that we need
to know about
are reactions between a halogen
and hydrogen
so hydrogen is just a gas so again i'm
just going to show you
the really simple equation again again
this is really really straightforward
hydrogen plus chlorine so again
here's my halogen here and i make
hydrogen now this is chlorine when it's
by itself but it's in the compound pound
it's chloride
hydrogen chloride so just to show you
the um how this looks underneath
hydrogen is h2 chlorine
is cl2 and hydrogen chlor
chloride is hcl just need to put a two
in front
to balance it so what we need to know
about this compound
our hydrogen chloride is the fact that
it's these are called
hydrogen halides
so look it's very similar to having when
we react
a halogen with a metal we make a metal
halide
when we react hydrogen with a halogen we
get a hydrogen halide
now these hydrogen halides actually
dissolve in water
to make acidic solutions for example
2hcl this would dissolve in water to
form
hydrochloric acid which is a strong acid
so as you can see those first two types
of reactions are very very simple
the next type of reaction that halogens
we need to know about
involving halogens are displacement
reactions now all a displacement
reaction is
is when a more reactive element replaces
a less reactive element
so we're going to have a look at this
example here here we have chlorine
all by itself and we have potassium
bromide
so potassium and bromine in a compound
here
now if we have a look at our halogens
as you go basically at the top you have
your most reactive elements
and the further you go down your group
you get less and less reactive
so if we look at the two different
halogens here chlorine and bromine
we can see that chlorine is more
reactive than bromine
so because chlorine started by itself it
will be able to replace this bromine
because it's more reactive if it
replaces it so instead of now having
potassium bromide
i would now have potassium
chloride again look how it ends eyed now
it's in a compound
but that's not all the bromine has now
been replaced it's been kicked out
so now i just have the bromine
all by itself
so to quickly show you this is a symbol
equation underneath
it would look like this
kcl plus br2
and just to balance it i need a 2 there
and a 2 there
so remember a displacement reaction
is when a more reactive element
replaces a
less reactive element
and we can actually see this we can
actually show the reactivity
of the halogens by doing a series of
reactions
so what we have here is potassium
chloride solution which is a colorless
solution
potassium bromide solution which is
colored this solution
and potassium iodide solution what each
box represents
is a reaction between one of these
things
and one of these solutions so remember
if we've got displacement reaction we
must have a more reactive element
replacing a less reactive element
so let's go through and have a look if
we'd see any reactions so first of all
chlorine and chlorine so
the halogen here is chlorine the
hydrogen here is chlorine one
isn't more reactive than the other
they're the same level of reactivity
so we would not see a reaction here
this time we've got chlorine water
and the halogen is bromine so the
chlorine
would displace the bromine and we'd see
a change in color because bromine water
is a kind of orangey color this one here
if we react to chlorine water with
potassium iodide
the chlorine is more reactive than the
iodine it's higher
in group seven so it would displace the
iodine
and we'd actually get a brown solution
because iodine water is brown
so let's have a look at this one if we
reacted bromine water
with hydrogen oh sorry potassium
chloride
we could see that bromine is less
reactive than chlorine
so it would be not be able to displace
it
bromine and bromine have the same level
of reactivity
so we would not see a displacement
reaction but
bromine is more reactive than iodine
so the bromine would replace the iodine
and the iodine would be left in the
water to give a brown color
now finally if i added iodine to any of
these solutions
iodine isn't more reactive than chlorine
bromine or iodine
so none of this bottom row i would see a
reaction
so those are the three different types
of reactions
involving halogens thank you